the end of a long road for mep s who for
months have been scrutinizing the troika
and the social and economic impact of
the budget slashing measures its pushed
in the four countries that have needed
EU bailout Portugal Cyprus Ireland and
Greece the troika was set up in 2010 and
brings together the European Central
Bank European Commission and the
International Monetary Fund from the
start its courted controversy which
spilled into this week's debates Moscow
technocratic that we carry sakakibara
motel in foot economic avec la política
Street Alexis XO chewy latika blue jean
me so and this from one of two MEP is
leading an inquiry into the troika and
the impact of the fiscal austerity
measures it's been pushing local
situation or prob so manga hospice ido
democracy ill dude delhi fickes ET de
política austerity you support the
Misawa the co-leader of the inquiry
acknowledged flaws and shortcomings but
wanted to point to the future long
plastic won't be a dental patient we are
also after important as commander of
traits Democratic Leggett Amir tortoises
house control yet font Eason house owned
the ballet honk and a ganache tart when
God for hint along skies AT&T vegas 11
mr. choruses group believes the troika
has served its purpose more Savior than
monster model is on shaky eps estoy con
cuidado napoli kasam des métiers d'art
read odd Kanaan polyphase airport in
causal she met economic named pauline
conceived with my spot simply with youth
unemployment at record levels and social
deterioration all-round some MEP is
called for swifter more socially
friendly measures estamos iroha nose
pero no Kearney Pharaohs poor Don una
política cake comprend a'kla vida es más
completa que salvar los millones de los
bancos ilaria publican dos anos both
reports come at the initiative of
parliament and a non-binding
recommendations but any piece are hoping
their voice has been so consistent so
loud and so urgent that there